[Musique]
le plot
l'euro notre nounours et bien joyeux ce
soir à tron nous allons nous amuser je
connais des devinettes très difficile
que nicolas et pimprenelle ne
connaissent pas et qu'ils ne trouveront
jamais
il me tarde de voir ça c'est moi qui
vais être le plus fort ce soir europe on
l'échelle hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop bombe au
phosphore ni colle en bronze pas preneur
écoutez moi bien le premier on lit à
granules
je lui pose une de zine el
kassam a
et tous les deux en même temps la ville
et bien je vous poserai e devinettes et
vous jouerez tous les deux
voyons au louvre pour entrer on la ferme
quand on sort qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
elle a aussi une clu
mais oui moi je les aime pas la dînette
de porte à une autre elle est très
difficile celle là
elle mange beaucoup d'herbe et elle fait
[Musique]
bravo nicolas
allons y l'état
voyons né à bell le fabrique et les
enfants le monde
qu'est-ce que seul
[Musique]
oui
il aime beaucoup
une dernière on se couche pas dans es on
se cache dessous qu'est ce que c'est
allons ce facile
mais c'est le lit
et de talent vous y un ours et vous
dormez la jette à la lui bien
bonne nuit
on annonce l'année
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants le boulgour aux
arbres vallée nos patrons j'étais le
plus fort ce soir n'ont pas trouvé mais
deux finales vraiment nounours enfin
bras tout le rôle de l'alhambra route
mon nounours venue des enfants n'oubliez
pas de faire votre toilette
bien vous laver les dents embrassez vos
parents est fait pour eux
[Musique]
e